one of my favorite people in the world
we get to talk to you for a few minutes
here doctor art Laffer is economic
acumen and influence in triggering a
worldwide tax-cutting movement in the
80s joined him the moniker caused him to
have the moniker of the father of
supply-side economics he was a member of
President Reagan's economic and policy
advisory board and I served on President
trumps economic recovery task force and
was recently awarded the Presidential
Medal of Freedom from the president dr.
art Laffer joining us to talk about the
economy I thought that would be very
important how are you doc fine how are
you doing doing good ken Coleman's
co-hosting with me today that you know
well yes I do
I can doctor laugher always good to hear
from you sir so so the study that you
guys did at laugher associates is
predicting a with the fast reopening of
state economies that the American
America's recession could end as early
as late summer swift recovery in the
fall true you know the markets are
telling us that things look really
attractive if you look at the stock
market it's a it is down that's true but
nothing like it was in 2008-2009 or like
in 74 or like it was in the y2k problem
the market is telling us this is going
to be a very quick downturn but a quick
upturn back up which looks very nice to
me it makes me very happy I I was
worried there for a little bit that it
was going to be a lot stronger and lot
deeper I really don't think that's the
case I'm hearing you're out there in the
land you know II or if it's so bad and
the Great Depression is upon us so you
don't you don't think there's a Great
Depression era coming no this is not
going to be a Great Depression at all I
mean a couple of things are very nice as
well
they're not nice they're much less bad
than they were all the original
forecasts of the deaths and the spread
of the virus and how fatal it was all of
those were a little bit higher than ever
it turned out to be the case which is
wonderful which means the the death toll
is going to be a lot less it's a lot
focused so I I think there's a lot of
good news and the latest news now is
that we're well on our way towards a
vaccine which would be absolutely
spectacular oh absolutely
we can all agree on that so you guys are
advising not only the White House and
you're not only a in the White House
regularly with President Trump and with
this task force but you're also talking
a lot of governor's across the country
right I have been yes I've talked to a
lot of them are you gonna see the you
think you're gonna see the recovery be
spotty based on their policies and how
quickly they reopen yes yeah there are
two things that really hit here Dave
that are really very very important
number one the corona virus was not even
handed in its attacks on different
states New York just got hammered I mean
I think the death toll per million
people was like 50% higher than the next
highest that would be New Jersey and the
top five I think are I mean the seventh
one down is like a fifth the type of
mortality rate that hit New York so it
was very selective in the states that
hit and also these states have very
different policies and how to open up so
these states that were hit hard off also
happened to be the states that have the
most top-down D released type of
governments they really don't want to
have the freedoms to reopen so it's
going to be a double whammy on those I
mean I look at you know New York New
Jersey Connecticut Illinois
Massachusetts Michigan and Wisconsin
those types of states are going to be
hammered states that are open much more
free that have less impact of
coronavirus Arizona Washington Texas
Utah you know in South Carolina Colorado
for example is a really wonderful one
they're going to be coming back very
quickly Texas has a special problem
which is the hydrocarbon the price of
oil dropped very very sharply they'll
have a specific impact on Texas and
Wyoming in West Virginia and Alaska and
in North Dakota but but those states are
generally speaking are not going to do
well the oil States but but the ones
that are low tax rates pro-growth states
with good governors are going to come
out really well I think
are we heard this week from the Fed
chairman pal that 40% of people making
$40,000 or less lost their jobs
obviously there's a tremendous amount of
hourly wage earners in that number and
that's a devastating number but I'm
wondering if you see the positive side
here too as these states open up and the
service industry that was hit
terrifically hard that those jobs many
of those jobs are going to come back
quickly because places are opening I
think that's true but yeah there's a
little weird twist here that's sort of
it
in this very bad carrot sight so the one
thing that's really hurt the economy
most even worse I think than the
coronavirus is a cares act you know that
was a three trillion dollars PPP program
it raised it gave unemployed people 600
bucks per week extra above that and what
it's done is it's made it be unemployed
and far more economically attractive
than going back to your job and you know
that was just a disaster to do that and
a lot of these people you're talking
about are now getting unemployment
benefits that you know never their
regular unemployment benefits plus
$31,000 a year extra for not working and
so that makes it their incentive to go
back to work a lot less and should be
yeah and so and if they don't go back to
work that slows the recovery right yeah
and now there was a very funny thing
today if any of you saw it on by
secretary Mission who said they're gonna
pass a rule that you don't get the $600
per week or the unemployment benefits if
you get offered a job at your old salary
you've got to take it or other or else
they'll withdraw the unemployment
benefits you know what they're getting
way too many rules and regulation here
they shouldn't have put the benefits in
in the first place yeah we had
unemployment insurance that was plenty
large for taking temporarily taken care
of people who were without the job and
then the federal government has to come
in and try to mess around with all this
stuff and now they're trying to undo it
with another regulation in it it's
getting to be an awfully complicated
process and well and it appears to July
25th that the dates are going to run
through that this that the federal $600
runs there is way too long I mean it's
great don't they understand that if you
baby
to do something they'll do more of it
what's so surprising about that if you
pay people not to work they will not
work hello scuse me but you know I've
been involved in these processes now
since I was in the White House with
Nixon
when he did the Camp David thing and you
know whenever politicians make decisions
when they are either panicked or drunk
as you say David the consequences are
rarely attractive and that is exactly
what you're seeing now you're seeing
unified politicians making very bad
decisions that make the system a lot
worse yes this blue mark huh in some
cases they might have on both panicked
and drunk people you and I have had lots
of discussions over the dinner table and
even on the microphone over the years of
people businesses that create jobs
without government doesn't and
individuals leaving states with a high
income tax and that you've done plenty
of studies and I've read them and quoted
them that the states with no income tax
have outperformed economically the
states with an income tax do you think
that I think we're going to see that
magnified the migration out of the
California's and out of the New York's
if they don't open up like people are
going to run out of there like are
hurricanes coming at that place yeah I
think it's going to be much more than
New York's to Connecticut's the Michigan
see in New Jersey's those states
California is a story unto itself our
friend Larry Gatlin said if you haven't
played in California it hits a brand-new
game but other than California I think
is very true I think the the salt tax
the state and local tax deduction
limitation also makes it much more
expensive for high-income earners to
stay in those states so I think we're
gonna see a lot of migration out of
those states doctor around 8 I'm sorry
go ahead yeah dr. art Laffer father
supplies out economic serving on
president Trump's economic recovery task
force laugher associates coming out with
a study this week predicting a fast
reopening in the states that have a fast
reopening that any recession that we're
feeling would
in those areas by late summer dr. Lappe
are always honor to be with you my
friend thanks for hanging out with us
wonderful they're wonderful I love
hanging out with you by the way you and
that you and Sharon of my favorites by
the way just so you know yeah we believe
you you're our favorite as well brother
this is the Dave Ramsey show